be commended that we're not texas
that we're new york our country is home
of the free land of the brave
we do not be cap become cowards and send
people away to looking looking for help
so that was democratic new york city
mayor eric adams once again blaming
texas governor greg abbott and arizona
governor doug ducey as an influx of
migrants overwhelmed city resources here
in new york my guy benson is the
political editor for townhall.com he's a
fox news contributor and guy i think
that takes a lot of
basically ignorance first of all the
governors of texas and arizona are not
sending
migrants to new york guy
a little bit of hutzpa there from the
mayor of new york city and we saw a
similar complaint recently dana from
mayor bowser here in washington d.c
where migrants are being bussed directly
from texas and i can imagine governor
ducey and arizona governor abbott in
texas looking at these mayors and saying
okay please break out the world's
smallest violin for us here with your
whining and whinging about having a tiny
drop in the bucket of what our states
and our communities at the border have
been experiencing every single day
month after month after month as a lot
of these big city blue city mayors cheer
on the problem declare themselves you
know sanctuary cities and that sort of
thing then when they get just a taste of
what it's like they come out
complaining and attacking the border
states and saying all these straining
our resources like yeah welcome to our
world say the border states and those
leaders abbott spokesperson governor
abbott down in texas so his spokesperson
said this that mayor adams should check
with president biden if his
administration is the one dumping
migrants in his city as they've been
doing to texas border towns for months
so yes the anger is misguided though i
think this what's also interesting is
you've heard rumors i'm sure that
mayor adams might have aspirations for
higher office one day and there's this
curious thing in politics of the of late
where
if you just fight or if you call someone
name or if you just want to be angry
like the left wants biden to be much
more angry all the time and to be angry
and screaming and yelling and which
doesn't accomplish anything imagine guy
if eric adams said you know what i'm
gonna go visit the del rio mayor i'm
gonna go see what it's like down at a
border town in texas and have some
appeal maybe be the first democrat to go
down to visit the border towns and
actually see what's going on there's
never any sort of creative thinking to
order to advance the ball here guy
well if he did that he might learn
something and we can't have that right
you're right i mean look it's a lot of
tribal fighting that's the name of the
game we see governor newsom in
california presiding over so many
failures just punching it up with ron
desantis in florida and other red state
governors that's his approach i guess to
gaining national prominence i think that
whether it's bowser or adams or news or
anyone else certainly biden or harris
they could go down to the border and try
to
actually ingest information by talking
to people who work down there people on
the front lines men and women trying to
protect the country trying to enforce
the law with one hand tied behind their
back because of these policies of the
administration we've had four
consecutive months now in the united
states dana with 200 000 or more
apprehensions at the border and people
say oh well that means that the border's
not open because people are getting
caught
it's not completely open but it is
certainly not closed and it is certainly
not secure because in each and every one
of those months as bill malugan
chronicles all the time
there have been tens of thousands
sometimes north of 50 000 known godaways
people who just escaped into the country
that we didn't have the resources or
personnel to catch and over the course
of this administration under this
president we are approaching getting
closer and closer to a million known
godaways a million which is much larger
than the entire population for example
of delaware the president's home state
so it is a massive problem the crisis is
raging and to see this type of sniping
political sniping with ignorance out of
ignorance which was your word and i
agree with it i think does nothing to
help solve the problem also like maybe
just pick up the phone rather than put
out a tweet or put up press release
there's a thing called the phone
president obama remember that remember
he had a pen and a phone just quickly i
wanted to ask you about this olympian
who uh ditched america to compete for
china you might remember her in the
olympics eileen goo well okay that's
fine that's her decision but a new
decision is coming forward and that is
she just won a big award an espy award
what do you make of that
yeah espn decided to bestow upon her a
breakout athlete of the year award do
they mean breakout isn't like breaking
out of her american citizenship status
because she renounced this country she
grew up here she was trained here she
had all the privileges and amazing
rights of being an american went to
stanford living a dream but it wasn't
enough she wanted to go to china
communist china which is hosting the
genocide games while they're actually
prosecuting an act of genocide and go
compete under their flag so she gave up
her citizenship here saw dollar signs
over there and it's worked out well for
her economically i think a lot of
americans say okay i mean that's a
choice you made i think morally a very
questionable one but do we need to
celebrate that choice here in the united
states of america as espn did at the
espys i don't think so uh but that's
what they chose to do all right guys
benson thank you for being here have a
great weekend we'll see you next
week thanks dana
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now